[Music]
camila cabello's new music video for
don't go yet
is an 80s dream
with its totally 80s hair makeup and
wardrobe
the whole video is a telenovela tribute
and some of these dance scenes are
giving us major
beetlejuice vibes
it's all reminiscent of this scene from
the classic film
[Music]
camilla also made use of miniatures in
her opening credits of the music video
just like the 1988 blockbuster
camilla opened up about the creative
process along with a clip of don't go
yet on instagram
writing in the caption that the song was
written after listening to cuban music
and playing with her pup tarzan i feel
like i just know what's important
in life right now and that her entire
new album familia
was inspired by family and her chosen
family
aka her friends and food i want to do
this differently than i ever did it
before
the 24 year old cuban singer did not
disappoint with the visuals
not only were there nods to the cult
classic film beetlejuice
but camilla made a statement with her
backup dancers in a scene
that looks a lot like the last supper
and there were also some cameos
including drag race alum
valentina who appears in both female
presenting drag
and male presenting drag
camilla spoke to apple music's zane lowe
about finding herself through her new
music
you seem to have further identified your
roots through your music and you seem to
be going there totally well i
love being latin this album for me
was like a manifestation like i i
the name of my album is familia
and and um i think i was like really
manifesting
um i was really inspired by when i saw i
don't know if you saw
tangana's tiny desk no i haven't shout
out to
setangana because i'm a huge fan of his
um
and like in the tiny desk he's basically
doing the tiny desk at this dinner table
and he's got like a ton of people around
him and there's like half eaten like
food
and i was so inspired by that and i was
like that's the life i'm trying to have
like for me it's like
it's really become like not about
you know not about success not about
obviously like if you win with your
friends like that's incredible but
i think like it's really become about
that kind of life for me she went on to
say her life and priorities shifted
during kovid
to spending more time with family and
her beau
shawn mendes in miami she's amazing like
super talented as songwriter like i've
never worked with the actual songwriter
who i clicked with as well as to her
speaking of sean the 22 year old singer
praised his queen on social media
sharing a screenshot of the don't go yet
music video to his instagram story
in celebration of camilla's first song
off her new album
writing so happy for you this beautiful
song
and this beautiful wave of music and
finished off the sentiment with
go me raina
you